Olivia Wilde vows at the 2016 Oscars
Valentino ostomate Valentino yes ode
Couture and it's very comfortable so far
I've no complaints
the actress looked at the role in the
stunning ivory colored gown part of
Valentino's new spring collection
check out Olivia side-by-side with this
runway shot and look at this sweet photo
of her in fiancé Jason Sudeikis mint
combo as they host together on the
star-studded red carpet can we see
what's going on in the back oh wow I
wanted to show this how fantastic what
people may not be able to see how TV is
is this kind of sheer netting there do
that come on no risk tonight risk I love
that how is it being here tonight and
walking this red carpet and also the
pressure of finding the perfect I have
to say it's a good feeling here
I think everyone's really relieved that
this marks the end of award season so
there's just a nice vibe it's not too
hot I'm really honored to be here
tonight as a presenter and as the
producer of a nominated short
documentary so this is just wild it's
totally surreal
you